في ليبيا رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عبد الحميد دبيبه رئيس المجلس
الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري ورئيس مجلس
النواب عقيله صالح بمواصله التسبب في
الاحباط لدى الشعب الليبي بتجاهل ضروره
اجراء الانتخابات
في كلمته خلال اجتماعي مجلس الوزراء في
طرابلس النعامه 2023 سيكون عام وحده
المؤسسات واجراء انتخابات معتبرا ان هناك
اتفاقا بين رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
ورئيس مجلس النواب بهدف تعطيل اجراء
الانتخابات
تعليق التواصلي مع مجلس النواب وتزانيا
بين رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس
الدوله
الحكومه
الجزيره احمد خليفه احمد دعنا نبدا باهم
النقاط في رايك التي تحدث عنها عبد الحميد
طبيبه في كلمته
يمكن القول عثمان ان النقطه الاساسيه التي
يرتكز عليها خطاب عبد الحميد بيبه او
حديثه امام مجلس وزراء حكومته هو اتهامه
لرئيسين مجلس النواب والاعلان الدوله
عقيله عقيله صالح وخالد المشري بابرام ما
وصفها بالصفقات المشبوهه للاستمرار في
السلطه هذا الاتهام ياتي في خضم انسداد
سياسي حقيقي عثمان تعيشه البلاد او ما
يمكن وصفه بانقلاق السياسي او الجمود
السياسي الكبير الذي تعيشه البلاد منذ
اشهر وسط مطالبات باجراء الانتخابات هناك
مطالبات شعبيه وحزبيه وايضا عبد الحميد
البيبان لم يتوقف عن المطالبه باجراء
الانتخابات التي تبني المراحل الانتقاليه
في البلاد لكنه يتهم عاجله صالح وخالد
المشري
باجراء صفقه مشبوها كما وصفها للاستمرار
في السلطه هنا تشدر الاشاره الى ان خالد
المشري على سبيل المثال وهو في السلطه منذ
العام 2012
وبالنسبه لعيله صالح وفي السلطه منذ العام
2014 العام الذي اجريت فيه اخر انتخابات
تشريعيه في البلاد وبعدها دخلت البلاد في
اتون ازمه سياسيه واكون حروب انتهت بالحرب
على طرابلس عام 2019 و 2020 اذا نحن الان
امام تصريحات لعبد الحميد دبيبه تتهجم
خصومه بانهم يريدون التمديد لانفسهم
وبالتالي هذا ان هو يمكن القول هو نوع من
الضغوطات التي اصبحت يمارسها عبد الحميد
في الاونه الاخيره على عقيله صالح وخالد
المشري كي يدفائهما باتجاه بالتوافق على
هذا
همم
بالنسبه
العقيده صالح وخالد المصري اللذين
يتهموهما عبد الحميد الدبيبه هل هناك
موقف واضح من موضوع الانتخابات وانهاء
الفتره الانتقاليه كما يطالب به رئيس
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
المطلوب من الاثنين عقيله صالح وخالد
المشري هو التوافق على قاعده دستوريه هذا
التوافق عثمان لم يصل اليه الرجلان حتى
اللحظه حجر العثرى في هذا التوافق كما
ذكرت في وقت سابق هو اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر تفصيل ذلك هو ان عقيله صالح
يريد وضع شروط في القاعده الدستوريه
وتحديدا في شروط الترشح للرئاسه تسمح
لخليفه حفتر بالترشح للرئاسه هذه النقطه
يرفضها خالد المشري ويقول انه لا يجب او
لا ينبغي اليه العسكريين الترشح للرئاسه
وايضا لحامله الجنسيه الثانيه غير الجنسيه
الليبيه فهذه حجر العثرى في التوافق بين
الطرفين اما ما سواها من شروط الترشح
للرئاسه وبقيه بنود القاعده الدستوريه
فالرجلان متفقان عليها تبقى فقط مساله
ترشح العسكريين وايضا ترشح حمله الجنسيه
الثانيه وهي التي لم تجعل يا صالح وخالد
المشري يصل الى توافق حتى هذه اللحظه بشان
هذه القاعده الدستوريه هناك ضغوطات من عبد
الحميد بيبه وايضا هناك ضغوطات من البحث
الامميه وايضا من الولايات المتحده على
عقيله صالح وخالد المشري انه لابد من
الوصول الى توافق لاجل القاعده الدستوريه
كيف كيف
يمكننا عبر بيان نعم يعني كيف يمكن حسم
هذه النقطه يعني هل الى الى مطالبه هل من
المهم مثلا موقف حكومه الوحده الوطنيه من
موضوع من يحمل الجنسيه الثانيه او من همم
ترشح العسكريين خاصه حفتر يعني وبالتالي
هل ما هو موقفها وهل موقفها مؤثر في همم
حسم هذا التعثر
بالنسبه لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه او عبد
الحميد البيبه الان هو طرف طرف سياسي يمكن
وصفه بالطرف السياسي القوي في مشهد الازمه
الليبيه اسوه بالاطراف الاخرى كعجيله صالح
وخليفه حفتر وخالد المشري وبالتالي هذا
الموقف المتعمق من من عبد الحميد دبيبه له
الاثر الكبير في الضغوطات على الرجلين
لاجل ضروره التوافق على قاعده الدستوريه
خصوصا وان هذا الراي من عبد الحميد بيبه
تسانده او تدعمه واقف اماميه ممثله في همم
موقف لممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده او
المبعوث الامم يا عبد الله باتيلي وايضا
الولايات المتحده التي طالبت منذ ايام عبر
بيان همم نشارته على منصاتها الرسميه طالب
المبعوث الاممي في ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي
باللجوء الى بدائل اخرى لانتاج قاعده
دستوريه وتجاوز عقيله صالح وخالد المشري
اذا لم يصل الى ااا توافق الخلاصه نحن
امام انسداد سياسي او انغلاق
سياسي كيفيه الخروج منه حتى الان غير
معروفه الامم المتحده ليست لديها اليه
واضحه حتى الان للخروج من هذا النفق الذي
تعيشه البلاد ايضا عقيله صالح وخالد
المشري لم يصل الى توافق حتى هذه اللحظه
وبالتالي هذا يعني استمرار الازمه على ما
هي عليه وعدم اجراء همم الانتخابات رغم
انه عبد الحميد بيبه اليوم تحدث عن ان
العام 2013
سيكون عام الانتخابات في ليبيا لكن كيف
ذلك لا احد يدري حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك
همم احمد خليفه